all right we got one more and it's the
one that really sort of blew this thing
up over the last say five or six months
uh into a cultural phenomenon and this
of course is everything happening over
at disney so chris ruffo who i just
mentioned who's been on the show many
times uh he got this video we've shown
this on the show i think twice already
uh an internal chat that they were
having over at disney this is disney
executive producer latoya ravenow
and they were having a whole thing on
diversity and inclusion and equity and
how they spread messaging within their
movies etc etc take a look it's like i
love disney's content i grew up watching
you know all of the classics they have
been a huge like informative part of my
life but at the same time like i worked
at small studios most of my career and
i'd heard you know you hear whispers
like i heard things like oh you know
they won't let you show this at a disney
show and i'm like okay so i was a little
like sus when i started and but then
my experience was
bafflingly the opposite of what i had
heard on my little pocket of like you
know proud family disney tva um
the showrunners were super welcoming
meredith roberts and like the our
leadership over there has been so
welcoming to like my like not at all
secret gay agenda and so like i i feel
like
i felt like it was i mean like maybe it
was that way in the past but i guess
like something must have happened in the
last like like they are turning it
around they're going hard and then
all that like momentum that i felt like
that
sense of i don't have to be afraid to
like
let's have these two characters kiss
let's in the background like i was just
wherever i could just basically adding
queerness to like if you see anything
queer in the show i'm proud of them but
like i just was like no one would stop
me and no one was trying to stop me all
right so she's got her not so secret gay
agenda then one of the other executives
there was going on and on about her gay
kid and her pansexual child and a whole
bunch of other things now i don't have a
problem with gay people i'm i'm actually
married to a gay guy so i'm usually okay
with gay people um except when dinner's
late
but this idea that they are telling you
what they are doing again and this is
with children this is with children and
there was a further video that came out
after this where disney ceo bob chappie
basically begging for forgiveness from
these people that he has not been a good
enough
ally to all of these people uh marissa
you mentioned prageru kids before i mean
i'm at the sort of just build new things
and let disney burn point are you there
already well i'm definitely there first
of all i'll say that i also have no
problem with gay people i happen to have
a very good uh
friend who's married to a gay guy uh and
so you know because i know they'll just
love to attack us because we just say
anything right um but it makes me
frankly sad i grew up with disney uh and
there is no baby better babysitter than
the television every once in a while
where i want to cook dinner or or take a
bath or relax or something but now i
can't trust uh disney anymore because i
don't know what kind of garbage is gonna
go into my kids brains unless i watch
every second of it before i allow my my
kids to watch it and so a couple of
years ago that kind of anxiety as mama
bear has led me to really build another
enterprise here at prageru and that's
prageru kids because i know that all of
us as parents do want to be able to turn
on the television and allow our children
to watch something that we can trust and
that we know would nourish their brain
and not hurt their brains and so we did
launch prageru kids and we now make
edutainment for every single age
kindergarten all the way through
if you're 104 we have content for you as
well but really the goal here is so that
there is something that parents can
trust that is going to be good for them
that is going to be wholesome and like
what stephen is doing we can complain or
we can also take action and try to
provide some services to a very large
audience that is interested in an
alternative choice so that people can
have the option of voting with their
feet there is somewhere else to go and
so if you don't like what disney is
producing at the very least you now know
that you can download prageru kids and
have your children watch something that
is going to be good for them and that
you can trust so speaking of doing
something last week i went to the belly
of the beast myself i went to orlando
home of disney with scary ron desantis
and here's what happened all right so
first off we have to start with the
obvious one
gay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
he didn't even flinch
nothing
stephen the stormtroopers did not burst
in they did not arrest me i said gay to
him he actually uh met my husband for
the second time right before that took a
picture with us they've given us baby
onesies um it's just
endless onslaught of nonsense huh
well i mean i think we we need to i mean
it it's the other one you put dye in the
water so you can see kind of like you
know where the water stream is going i
mean anyone can tell that these
ideological coercions are coming from
the university the university is
upstream of absolutely everything else
it's it's from there that you get the
teachers colleges that marissa was just
talking about policy politics
culture architecture art and so on it
all starts in what happens in the
university and i think we also need to
be pretty frank i mean conservatives can
spare me the outrage frankly you know
william f buckley wrote god man at yale
in 1951 that 71 years ago alan bloom
closing the american mine 1985 nearly 40
years ago i mean if people who want to
call themselves conservatives in the
small c sense like we're looking to
preserve the best of what we've
inherited had founded new colleges and
universities 30 40 50 even 20 years ago
we'd be living in a different country
right now so it's either put up or shut
up in my opinion i love it man that's
the opportunity and that's what you're
doing so it's it's absolutely perfect uh
deborah i mean you saw this of course
years ago at the research level too
so it's just
it's just absolutely everywhere and and
you changed your life because of it
right uh i won't be redundant because
i'm sure your audience has heard me say
this a million times we did talk about
this the first time i was on your show
but i left academia because gender
ideology had gotten so insane and now
i'm a journalist and you know i really
applaud marissa and steven for what
they're doing because i think it is so
important to be fighting back against
this and i think the the fastest way to
put parents off of trans rights and gay
rights is to force feed it to their
children in programming behind their
backs and i think they are totally
insane to think that parents are just
going to roll over and let activists
take over their kids minds
so i think it's fantastic what ronda
sans is doing and he's not he's not
backing down and i think we need more of
that